- [Narrator] Side note, no bread makers
were injured in the making of this video.
As you can probably gather,
this is not your average bread maker.
Nor is this your average bread oven.
Nor is it your average bread.
This is shotis puri, and in Georgian
that translates to, well, bread.
- A tonir oven is essential
to the making of shotis puri.
After the oven is built
and the heat is turned up
to the highest level
for six to seven hours,
the walls of the oven are
covered in a salt based liquid.
And diving in to get the
bread as close to the fire
is just a part of the job.
- As if diving into a clay
pot isn't intense enough,
this thing hits temperatures
of 750 to 900 degrees Fahrenheit.
The end result is a special
bread with a salty twist
that's eaten on special occasions,
like birthdays, weddings,
Christmas and New Years.
(bright music)